I'm really sorry this is Hollywood we
don't like liars
in 2007 knocked-up made waves as one of
the funniest movies of the year and
that's partially thanks to you Katherine
Heigl you did an amazing job at
portraying Alison Scott and viewers
loved what you and Seth Rogen brought to
the table so we were totally shocked
when we found out that you were the
casting directors second choice another
actress was all set to play Alison but a
minor onset conflict cost her the gig
it's hard to imagine what the movie
would have been like without you
Katherine you wouldn't believe how many
actors acted out and lost their jobs at
the very last second some of these
celebrities were kicked off their TV
shows while others never made it into
the credits keep watching to find out
which a-list ur gained a bunch of weight
for his role only to get fired for
putting on too many pounds Taylor Momsen
Taylor Momsen will always be remembered
as the adorable child actor who
portrayed Cindy Lou Who and How the
Grinch Stole Christmas but like most
child actors Taylor grew up very quickly
and endured her fair share of scandals
in 2007 Taylor scored the lead role of
Jenny Humphrey on the dramatic TV series
Gossip Girls but her character would
receive less and less screen time as the
series went on I thought we were doing
this together it's my plan and there's a
logical explanation for that as it turns
out Taylor took a page from Jenny's book
and went from being a good girl to a
total baddie producers complained about
Taylor's unreliable and erratic behavior
on set and things got so bad that Little
J eventually lost her spot as a series
regular by the end of the series Taylor
would be asked for the occasional guest
star appearance fans were sad to see her
go but according to producers Taylor's
dismissal was necessary this wasn't the
first time the actress would be
reprimanded for her bad behavior turns
out Taylor Momsen is Pretty Reckless
Chloe grace Moretz Chloe grace Moretz is
one of the most famous young celebrities
in the world she's worked alongside
big-time stars like Denzel Washington
and Julianne Moore and she's known for
her stellar work ethic and diverse
acting skills so knowing this it's hard
to believe that Chloe would ever get
fired from a project
but in 2008 that's exactly what happened
Chloe was all set to voice penny in
Disney's animated film bolt she put in
long hours at the studio and finished
recording the entire movie but at the
last second Chloe was fired and her rule
was given to Miley Cyrus in the end
Disney felt that Miley was a lot more
popular than Chloe and they believed her
voice to be more recognizable but
Chloe's hard work wasn't all for naught
because Disney still used Chloe's
footage to portray young penny in the
film Chloe who was 11 years old at the
time was still credited for the role but
the whole ordeal definitely left a
bitter taste in her mouth
Jessica Byul Jessica Biel has made quite
the name for herself in Hollywood she
starred in movies like The Illusionist
and the Texas Chainsaw Massacre and most
recently she appeared in ten episodes of
lime town but early on in her career
Jessica made a mistake that would cost
her her breakthrough role although this
scandal helped her land more mature
roles going forward jessica admitted to
regretting her actions
chances are you remember the TV series
seventh Heaven it aired from 1996 to
2007 and reruns of the show where aired
up until 2014 Jessica gained popularity
in the late 90s when she was cast as
Mary Camden on 7th heaven but in 2006
when Jessica was only 17 years old she
posed on the cover of gear magazine and
was immediately reprimanded Jessica's
scandalous photoshoot was much too
graphic for the WB so they chose to
write her character off the show Jessica
confessed that she regretted posing for
gear magazine but she kept her head held
high and moved on to greater things and
just one year later in 2007 7th heaven
was cancelled for good Megan Fox Megan
Fox started acting when she was only 15
years old and soon after she would
become one of the most popular actresses
of her generation whatever work I had
done up until that point I was always
the mean girl in 2004 Megan and Lindsay
Lohan starred in the movie Confessions
of a Teenage Drama Queen and by 2007
Megan would be cast as mikaela banes in
the blockbuster film transformers just
two years later Megan would reprise her
role in transformers revenge of the
Fallen
sadly she would not be asked back for
the franchise's third installment
instead she was replaced by actress
Rosie huntington-whiteley so what
exactly happened for Megan to lose her
breakthrough role well turns out Megan
and director Michael Bay bumped heads
while on set of Transformers causing
Megan to refer to him as the most
horrible person to work with she would
also go on to compare Michael to the
most despicable dictator that ever lived
prompting Michael to let her go
fortunately for Megan this comment
wouldn't end her career and she'd go on
to star in films like Jennifer's Body
and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 1 & 2
yeah my friends Steve Byrnes
back in the late 90s and early 2000
Steve Byrnes made waves as one of the
most kid-friendly actors on television
Steve starred on the TV series Blue's
Clues which quickly became every kid's
favorite show but in 2003 Steve would
throw in the towel and leave Blue's
Clues fans without a proper explanation
tons of rumors began circulating and the
final verdict was that Steve was an
addict who had passed away but that was
a total lie it wasn't until much later
that Steve chose to share the reason for
his departure as it turns out Steve was
29 years old by the time he left the
show it was obvious to him and to
producers that the clock was ticking on
top of that Steve was losing his hair at
a rapid pace losing my hair it was just
time and they didn't want him to lose
his youthful glow according to Steve the
decision was mutual and everyone who
worked on Blue's Clues was ready to move
on from the program are you subscribed
to the things yet we post daily videos
about your favorite movies TV shows and
celebrities so hit that subscribe button
if you haven't already and be sure to
click that Bell and turn on post
notifications so you never miss another
video go into your YouTube settings and
switch on notifications if you're
watching on your mobile
mitchel Musso mitchel Musso was welcomed
into disney channel's good graces when
he was just a tween he starred alongside
Miley Cyrus on the hit TV series Hannah
Montana and would go on to play King
Brady in pair of kings but in 2011
Mitchell would get caught up in a
scandal that would cost him his Disney
Channel role at the
I'm Mitchell was all set to appear in
Disney's prank stars unfortunately for
him he was caught driving under the
influence by police officers leading to
his arrest what's even more shocking is
that Mitchell was only 20 years old at
the time an underage drinking isn't
something that Disney executives want to
be associated with Mitchell lost his gag
on pair of kinks and he was replaced by
Adam Higgs
however Disney allowed Mitchell to keep
his voice acting role on Phineas and
Ferb in which he voiced Jeremy Johnson
it's really nice you to make something
for me I can't wait to see what you've
come up with
sadly Mitchell hasn't appeared in much
else since his arrest Ryan Gosling Ryan
Gosling is without a doubt one of the
most successful actors in the world so
it's hard to believe that a director
would fire him just one day before he
was scheduled to start filming Ryan got
his big break when he was cast as Noah
on the notebook but he has since then
reinvented his image Ryan is known for
going to extreme lengths to get into
character but in 2009 this totally
backfired on him
Ryan was cast as Jack in The Lovely
Bones he was all set to play Suzie's
father when he was suddenly replaced by
actor Mark Wahlberg director Peter
Jackson decided to relieve Ryan of his
role you're fired
I mean that's what you're saying but no
what you mean you mean is fired because
well Ryan had purposely gained a bunch
of weight the actor had his own unique
idea of what Jack should look like and
his vision clashed with Peters the Lord
of the Rings director couldn't see eye
to eye with Ryan's creative approach so
he gave him the boot now we're not
talking about 20 pounds here Ryan
literally put on 60 extra pounds to
achieve his desired dadbod look Janet
Hubert in the early 90s when the Fresh
Prince of bel-air was first introduced
Janet Hubert was cast as wills on Vivian
banks Janet was the perfect person for
this role and fans of the show loved her
but then suddenly in 1993 Janet was
replaced by actors Daphne Reed who would
portray aunt Vivian for the rest of the
series in the end Will Smith explained
why Janet's role was recast he said that
Janet refused to get along with him and
that if it was up to her the show would
be called the aunt viv of bel-air show
in the end the actress wanted the series
to focus more on her the
we'll and I was waiting in my heart
thinking somebody will come to me one
day and help me she felt like he didn't
deserve his success because he was a
snotty nosed Punk did this very day
Janet still credits well for ruining her
career but obviously it was her bad
attitude on set that ultimately got her
fired from the 90s sitcom Lisa Bonet if
you were a fan of The Cosby Show when
you were growing up then you know all
about Lisa Bonet and her character
Denise Huxtable Lisa portrayed Denise
from 1984 to 1991
and she also played Denise on the
spin-off TV series a different world but
things started to go south when Lisa was
cast in the 1987 movie angel heart Lisa
was folded by the show's producers for
filming a very mature scene which
ultimately put her in hot water with the
directors of the series in 1988 Lisa and
her then husband lenny kravitz announced
that they were going to have a baby
which is what officially led to Lisa's
departure from the show turns out the
writers didn't want to create a
pregnancy storyline for Denise and at
the way believe it or not but
oscar-winning actress Anne Hathaway was
supposed to star as Alison Scott in the
hit film knocked up and went through the
trouble of learning all her lines and
showing up to the set of the movie it's
only to get fired and replaced by
Katherine Heigl now Anne isn't someone
to shy away from her role she's a super
dedicated professional after all she did
chop off all of her hair and put herself
through a drastic weight loss regimen to
star in lame is Rob but in the end and
draws the line when it comes to
childbirth scenes and since knocked-up
has a very graphic childbirth scene this
was the final straw for Anne what you
want her to be and then she's better
because she curses Anne had already
started filming the movie when she
realized what was expected of her she
explained her concerns to director Judd
Apatow and when he realized that Anne
wouldn't budge he decided to recast the
role and that's it for the 10 actors
from your childhood who were fired on
set before you go tell us which one of
these stories surprised you the most in
the comments below thanks for watching
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up we'll see you next time on the
things